or Tasha Tasha where'd you grow up where
are you from originally from Oceanside
California down by San Diego yes tell me
what your family growing up family
growing up was um a single mother
um I had a half brother who was 12 years
older than me and she was always my mom
was always working to be a provider
since she was a single mom
so I had little
um little uh supervision I kind of had
to wing it from an early age and um or
my my brother would sometimes have to
take care of me growing up he was kind
of well not kind of everywhere we lived
had holes in the walls
because he had a bad temper he was an
alcoholic my brother and he sometimes
would hit my mother
um
so later on in life I chose men that had
similarities just like my brother which
ended up in domestic violence was your
brother kind of more of a father figure
role model that I had in my life where
was your dad
um my dad had restarted
um or had remarried and started a new
family so he was somewhere in California
you ever meet him yes yes
what kind of kid were you in high school
high school was I never did graduate
I was in a continuation high school out
in I believe it was considered Carlsbad
um
high school was hard
I was raped by one of my um
by one of my
persons that I went to school with by
one of my peers her father and I had
originally gone there to get a tattoo
and um
needing something needing a utensil if
you will to get high had led me into the
garage where he was
and so
that happened and the only thing that
has stopped anything was that um his his
mom had knocked on the door to the
garage we were going on several several
hours of being you know beat and raped
had resulted in a pregnancy
which I had to tell my mother then what
was going on because I needed her
consent to go ahead with the abortion
how old are you I was 17.
that led you in what kind of Lifestyle
after that were drugs part of your life
then
um yes I was already into drugs by the
time I was 14 I was in history class
when I was given methamphetamine
um I already knew because my peers were
on it and had been around them how it
was um being used and back then we
smoked it on foil or light bulb
um I I got all my housework done and
seems to be getting all my homework done
so I was happy with the results
unfortunately my mother didn't notice
the change in me because she was always
at work
um
my brother would sometimes come back to
visit us when things weren't going right
with him and his lady
um
sometimes he would take his anger out on
me because now I was at an age where he
felt that I needed um
some child wearing or whatever and so
that would result in me being him
getting violent with me when he would
drink
so I started running away to avoid his
Wrath and that's when I really got a
taste of the streets
and what kind of things are you doing to
support yourself
um drugs a lot of gang
um
Gang Lifestyle even though I am not
affiliated with the gang
a lot of the people that I hung around
with were in gangs back then
um you know just drug use experimenting
things of that nature
it's all the things
involved in the street life yes yes a
lot of things
um and um
always you know being a female you're
always
um I feel like a Target you know you
always need to be aware of your
surroundings and and things like that
um so so it's hard to stay safe unless
you know you have a means to protect
yourself
sex work been part of your your life
that was not later
um yes that was not until later in my
life um it was my late 30s
I had lost my kids about eight years ago
I lost my place of 10 years I had a
condo three-bedroom condo
after the kids I lost the kids I really
didn't care I didn't make any plans
to go live somewhere else to to go maybe
to detox or or rehab
so actually I was all packed up with
nowhere to move my things I think I was
going through clinical depression at the
time
um and I was just grieving my kids
almost as if
um they weren't alive anymore
um
so that's when things got really heavy I
think I was about nine days and
um
I had uh some some drugs that I could
have sold for money but everybody was
doing the same thing
um so after being hungry for about nine
days like hungry for food
nowhere particularly to lay my neck at
night that's when I started coaching
myself to maybe consider doing a date
and um
I thought well it's familiar before you
know I was having sex from a young age
and I kind of had to psych myself out to
be able to accomplish that um
I I went on the date and I kept my
composure and afterwards I remember
thinking that was not that bad
that's something that I could probably
um you know like be a boss and and and
be able to handle
um
I get high but I Stay
I I feel that I stay sober in a way that
you know I'm sober minded
um so I felt that I could handle that
lifestyle
you're kind of functional
even when you're using
I'm sorry you're kind of functional even
when you're using yes to a point
um I I could get a little
um shiny like my intentions are good and
I mean to be there uh you know prompts
but then the night before long night or
or unexpected events happen and you know
doesn't allow me to really be reliable
sometimes
so back to your kids you were married or
you had a relationship I had a
relationship with each of my children's
fathers
um all three of my kids have different
dads at the time I was in a relationship
with them living with them
um short-term relationships but all of
them except one abusive
um so we you know terminated that pretty
early in my pregnancy and I I kept the
pregnancy or kept the baby
um but just the father was not really
active in their lives did you raise your
kids yes
um to to until eight years ago I have a
21 year old a 17 year old and a 15 year
old
what happened at eight years into their
eight years
well I um
I met somebody immediately after those
nine days so I was already doing what I
was doing nobody had pushed me into it
um but I met somebody in the area that
was a local
um of the area I was working in and he
seemed to be pretty confident
um nobody seems to bother him and it
seemed like he got what he wanted and
nobody got in his way
so I didn't think I could make it um
survive out on the streets it was my
first time homeless so I kind of clung
to him
um in doing so we started a relationship
and I thought he was my boyfriend and
being naive I found out otherwise that
he was my pimp
um things got
brutal at times and um
I was basically told no you're taking
this job and sometimes I would be choked
out or or hit in the face
um you know just um
beat with a cane
just a lot of violence
and it took about two years to shake him
um if I ran and ran into him in public
um it would be like um he would get
violent on me it wouldn't matter if it
was daytime who was around he didn't
care
so finally we came to an understanding
and I never thought that that day would
come but he did he was able to move on
because he now had somebody else to
focus on
um and you've heard on your own since
then yes I I've worked on my own since
then
about six years now
almost
um homeless yes like
I am homeless in the sense that I do not
have my own home since I lost my place
um but I do not sleep on the streets at
night because it's not safe so for me I
have to have that answer for myself to
know where I'm going to rest my head at
night I should know that early in the
day but some days I don't I don't have
that answer
however I'm confident and and I know
that um I will have it so sometimes it's
a motel room sometimes
um I'll share you know like we'll go
halves me and another female
um not not always the best situations
but I always go for my safest um
what what seems to be the safest at the
time and feasible how does that
lifestyle affect you emotionally
um it has made me
um
what's the word um
sometimes callus at times sometimes
very separated from my emotions kind of
like robotic
um time is money and money is time so
um I'm always mindful of my of my time
and I've even caught myself on my
personal time looking at the clock
and thinking oh you know how much money
I'm losing
um
that's that's not something that I'm
proud of but there are emotional
um setbacks that that you find comes at
the surface you know later
and do the drugs help you do that the
drugs definitely help um meth from the
beginning had been like something to
numb my emotional
uh pain
um so it helps me to put that to the
back of my brain so I don't have to
maybe wake up and and feel that
trauma or reminisce on that or even just
my my daily
it helps me to cope it's like a mental
or emotional Band-Aid if you will
I would think it'd be hard to do this
kind of work without being drunk or high
right right
um I don't think that there's one woman
out there or anybody that does this type
of work and they come to it sober or
they've been doing it sober it's the
type of thing where you want to numb
your conscience down your conscious so
that you're able to um
you're able to perform or fulfill the
agreement turn off your feelings right
um
sometimes you know being vigilant is a
must for me
um I I have all these little safety nets
that I do and I keep them the same
um I noticed that early on when I wasn't
operating that way that's when I would
get into more things would happen or
mistakes certain details would be
overlooked that would be vital to me
later
you talk with your children still
I do
um
it's been about a month since I talked
to my my youngest son I was supposed to
go out to Phoenix
and the ticket was bought for Greyhound
from my mother
and it ended up that I I didn't I didn't
make it in time
it was just a Time issue and then um
me being so disappointed in that because
he was about to become ward of the state
I was just buried my head in this hand
um however I'm taking a greyhound out to
Phoenix probably tonight late tonight or
early tomorrow morning
I I don't know what I'm gonna walk into
um but I'm hoping everything's okay with
Jonathan and
um I'm hoping to get my life together
whether that means like 30 days in rehab
um CPS says that they have no uh legal
legal authority to keep him where he's
at so I can take him to where I'm at
except I don't have anything stable at
the time
so I was thinking of just going to
Phoenix I'm touching base seeing my son
and I hope to God that everything is
okay over there with the family
and um you know prove to um I really
don't have to prove because I can uproot
him but I'm not gonna do that until I
have something worth you know bringing
him to I'm not going to do that in my
wrong state of mind I want a legitimate
job a legitimate lifestyle now and I
think I'm finally at the point where I
mean it when I say I'm ready to close
the doors on all of this [__] and when I
do I'm going to close the doors on on
because these behaviors they go hand in
hand you know for me when I drink I want
to smoke cigarettes and then if I drink
too much then I need some meth and then
it becomes this Balancing Act
and um
you know even peers and things like that
I'm ready to um cut off uh the way that
I've been living
you seem like a very sensible woman
and yet you have been choosing to stay
on the streets rather than be there with
your kids what is it that
draws you to that destructive lifestyle
there is such a stronghold
um
with addicts and um
I had been doing this drug since I was
14.
it had become a sense of normalcy for me
so I have more time on it than I have
without it I um
gonna be 44 now
and I started when I was 14 so that's
like 30 years
um it's not an excuse because I I have
made a conscious decision
um every day that I use I'm taking a
risk but by then it's like the addiction
is already become so used to numbing
myself that I don't know what to expect
when I go through the detox over have
you tried before I tried once before I
had 11 days clean it's been about 11
years
since I had that many days clean
um with each pregnancy I would stop
as soon as I found out that I was
pregnant so I might have had six weeks
seven eight weeks of using and then
found out I was pregnant and I would
stay smoking cigarettes and then taper
myself off of the cigarettes
is it frightening to go back to
Square life after doing this for so many
years
it is it's almost like
um
I had to ask myself what am I so afraid
of
you know why do I get so close to having
um
people and support
opportunities and I I get so close and I
think I'm going to take them and then I
just get scared and I run like um
everybody that knows me they'll say that
I'm a runner if things get uncomfortable
you know I might dip out you're not
going to see me for a long time
um and and that's just the way that I've
been not coping with things
um
is that just your self-worth
sometimes I think that I am afraid of my
own success
I'm afraid to try something without a
crutch
um
you know I'm afraid to fail
I'm afraid to try something new
um even if it is good or it's something
pure you know
um
I'm afraid to fail again but you might
be afraid to succeed as well that's what
I was thinking yeah
I think you're right
um
I'm not too familiar with that I think
my my biggest accomplishments my most
beautiful accomplishments that I would
never take back are my three kids
after doing so many of these talks I
I see very clearly how if you don't
believe you deserve something yeah even
if you win the lottery you're going to
sabotage you're going to destroy it
somehow right if you don't believe you
deserve it right
if you earned it and and deep down in
your subconscious believe you
you deserve that you deserve what's
coming all the good things you know a
better life roof over your head right
good family good job good partner right
if you don't believe you deserve that
you'll you'll push it away right
yeah I I think that um
a lot of it is um
self-worth this type of work it does
affect your self-esteem
um you could be a very strong person and
certain things will come out when you
least expect it comes to this surface
and and be a trigger and you may or may
not be aware of it at the time so it
could be embarrassing you know just
going into tears and you're shopping
somewhere but maybe you saw
a little girl that reminded you of your
daughter when she was little you know
and um
things like that that there's sobering
moments you know
um but I'm one that I'm always trying to
keep my composure so it's like before
the next catastrophic thing comes you
know and it's not like woe is me I know
that I am no victim in this
um I kind of created my own path
and um
yeah it's hard
it's hard to um
keep your composure but the last thing
you want to do is seem weak and you know
curling up in a fetal position is not is
not an option for me I have to keep
going and I have to put my game face on
and
um because I'm out there alone I'm I'm
not oversaw by by management or whatever
you want to call it
um
or a pimp
security a driver whatever you want to
put it they get such polite terms right
right management right and there's no
such thing as Security in in this type
of work
um Street walking there's no such thing
as security would just be retaliation at
that point
because when you need the help of course
another man is not there with you yeah
you're on your own right
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done anything
differently
yes I would have I would have not
I would have not picked up meth
I wouldn't have um
meth has stole so much time from me
that I can't get back and um it has
taxed me tremendously that that I lost
my family
I refuse to be in a cup and ultimately
my refusals all of them counted as
dirties
for the drug that somebody was that knew
me well was saying that I had a long
history on
and had I just peed in the cup had I
just complied my kids would still be in
my life
right now you know
we would still be living together maybe
not my 21 year old because he lives um
he goes to ASU
um he's studying political science
but
we'd all be together like we were before
we were separated
yeah and
there's not a day that goes by that um
I don't have that gnawing feeling in my
stomach that that I've lost something
very precious to me so
I wish that um
I would have took heed earlier I mean at
least at the point of being a mother and
through my motherhood that that should
have been enough to sustain me
and um that I would have been more open
and sought to help
um so that I didn't relapse
Tasha what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life
the most important lesson that I've
learned
the
the streets don't love you
there's absolutely I could walk away
from all this right here by Skid Row
today
and Revisited 10 years later and not a
not a thing on the street is going to
change it's not like I missed anything
spectacular you know um I may have
dodged a toe tag you know
but
there's nothing that the streets can
fulfill in any void that you have you
you have to learn to love yourself where
you're at you know
um
meaning when you find yourself in in a
very low you know maybe bottom of the
barrel Low Bottom
um you still have to set that tone as to
how others are going to respect you so
you have to learn to love yourself first
um and be real with yourself if if
you're not sober don't take that chip
you know at any or or be real with
yourself and I find that the more honest
that you are with somebody sometimes
they could Network and even
um you know just you reaching out
um and and doing the right thing by
reaching out and being open and honest
in that way I feel like God will line
you up with your correct Destiny and
that's what I really um strive for at
the same time run away from
all right Tasha thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome I wish
you the best of luck thank you getting
back home